i also lost it the first time i met our
next guest he posted me up in a
in a basketball game once to show me
that i had no chance of ever even
thinking about being in the nba and
that's ryan hollins who played for 10
teams never played for the knicks
but i wonder if if they ever reached out
ryan
do you ever get a call from from uh the
new york knicks about
your services potentially during your
10-year mba career
they did and they they asked me to take
a pay cut they sent me a leather bag and
said there's nothing like being
in new york nick i said i'll pass so man
i've never been introduced
by the guy who's played for everybody
but the knicks only you
well it is great to have you on during
the nba finals as we as we anxiously
await who will win a ring bobby porter's
for langston galloway but ryan
when you look at game six coming up
phoenix on that flight that southwest
flight from phoenix to milwaukee what
could they possibly talking about
to feel any sense of confidence going
into
this coronation of giannis and the deer
district and the bucks winning their
first title in
i don't know 50 years here's the reality
chris paul didn't play well and now
milwaukee has gotten to a point where
uh they're playing good enough with
their we can call it
a big three a semi three whatever you'd
like to say where
you know phoenix has to play well you
need chris paul and booker in the same
game we've seen chris paul
play well we've seen booker play well
but we haven't seen it together
keep in mind also phoenix was in a
situation where they get out to a big
lead
and then not just doing they get up to a
big lead they had a chance to close the
game out or at least tie it at the end
and they turn over the basketball so in
in game
four what happens they get offensive
rebounded they give up the foul line
and then in this last game they turn
over the ball down the stretch when they
need a bucket so
these are fixable mistakes ultimately at
the end of the day and i thought the
boneheaded play
was chris paul they're only down one and
chris paul fouls giannis and makes the
worst playing basketball and gives him
an and one with the game on the line
you know let him dunk the basketball or
you know if you're gonna take them out
of the air take them out the air i don't
know but i think just let the guy dunk
it
at that point maybe contest it but don't
give up in anyone so
phoenix just they're showing their
inexperience at this time
i thought they definitely played hard
enough to win they gave themselves a
chance but
you know they're gonna have to share up
the little things because this isn't the
same boneheaded
milwaukee team we're used to playing
that's just bigger stronger faster
they're actually playing together and
i'm when i say that i mean
the adjustments that bucks made would
just play harder that's not the
adjustment in the nba finals and i
thought they
bud did a much better job coaching than
the guys bought into the ball movement
and that's something we were seeing from
phoenix earlier on and not from
milwaukee
ryan hollins joins the show 10-year nba
veteran ben lyons filling in for rich on
the rich eisen show ryan hollins posted
me up once in a charity basketball game
ryan when you look at the the the
phoenix suns
and the others mikhail bridges had 27
in game number two goes for four in game
number three
seven in game number four how can the
others
travel to milwaukee can the suns get
anything out of cam johnson
campaign maybe even an lg kick sighting
what do they do to get some support from
the role players and why don't role
players travel well
well it's all about the stars and and
the biggest thing that the road
the road starts to bring out is the
hustle points i mentioned it earlier
the bucks were plus 17 okay on the
offensive glass
they were minus 17 the suns as far as
turnovers were concerned
those are the hustle points the little
points you've got to they have to make
those efforts and that's going to be the
big difference in the game
so you ask one of the role players do
those are the controllables that the
role players give
you know i remember playing with the
boston celtics and i'm a role player my
job was to make sure paul pierce kevin
garnett and ray allen those guys were
comfortable
so they've got to defend they gotta dive
on the loose balls they've got a gang
rebound they have to make
all those little things so that chris
paul and devin booker can be the best
versions of themselves and especially on
the road
i've never been more uncomfortable in my
own skin when i'm in the presence of
kevin garnett
because that guy's really intense and
says some wild things
it just makes me feel really weird
what's it like to have the job of having
to make kevin garnett comfortable hey
man
he's one of the best teammates on the
entire planet as uncomfortable as he
makes big lions feel for his comments
against carmelo we're not going to dig
into those
we're going to get to new york next
that's a thing for you i know it's a
thing for you ben okay
but ultimately man he's one of the best
teammates ever and all he does is infuse
confidence into
his team and he's just an old-school
hard-nosed guy there was never a play
off never
shoot around we took off never a
practice out of place so
i tell you one thing you you would love
to get in the booth with kevin garnett
one day
he might turn ben lyons into a monster
just forgive him he was never a nick man
forgive him it's not his fault that the
knicks you know didn't go and get him
and free agency off the back i don't
know man but
forgive kevin garnett he's the best
teammate i've ever had and i owe him a
lot
i see a lot of kg and giannis in terms
of the intensity
in terms of the the way they lift up
their teammates i remember the footage
of game
i think it was two when giannis is
talking on the bench to his guys trying
to get them going
um how does how does giannis make others
better is it with his actual play on the
court or is it just his aura his
presence his intensity
you see a guy giving the effort that
giannis gives
you don't have any other excuse other
than play hard you know we can fault
giannis for the free throws
you know the three ball you know the you
know maybe lack of consistency and
scoring
but you can never lack his effort man
and he brings it every night and
and when you see a guy of his stature
with what he's accomplished
you know the rare two-time mvps one of
the rare players
to have an mvp and defensive player gear
in the same
darn gear you got to give a lot of
credit a lot of credit to yana san
sakupo for what he does
and you got to bring it and this is your
star player diving on the floor
this is your star player who hyper
extended the heck out of his knee and
then came out and played
as if as if it never happened you know
what i'm saying
a new york knick hyper extends his knee
and he's out for the entire season yeah
that comes back
a couple days later nick so ben you just
you gotta so
you gotta really take your hat off to
giannis and he's leading by example and
you know the skill set and all that
stuff is starting to come along
he's not quite there yet but his effort
is infectious on the floor ben
ryan if a new york nick hyper extends
his knee he gets a four year extension
in 50 million dollars
on the rich eisen show joined by ryan
hollins when you were watching the game
the other night ryan
and giannis was on the free throw line
and they cut to a phoenix suns fan
who was counting hundred dollar bills
did you think how does this guy make his
money
i was extremely confused i don't know
what that was i i don't know
it was like a weird flex like i i didn't
i didn't know
i i was phoenix doesn't know how to act
let's be honest
they haven't been in this situation the
nba finals in a very long they don't
know how to act
they're punching people in the stands by
by the way shout out to something for a
guy you know
no not shout out sons and four guys no
shout out sons and for
guy he's got a bobble head enough with
the shout outs dude is your legend
but the phoenix sun fans don't know how
to act have you noticed
they're acting like nick fans all of a
sudden man i don't know what's going on
no see nick fans would never coordinate
their t-shirts he gives
phoenix fans to say this section wear
orange just section
you know how many chase promotional
towels i have
commemorative 2011 playoff towels you
nick fans are on suspension they're on
timeouts after spitting on trey young
okay
you guys got some you guys did you guys
were flipping cars after one playoff win
okay you got something explaining no i
feel you on that and something we talked
about on the show earlier it was just
how fans like me are just behaving at
these
these these games it's absurd you know
you're much you're a much better
wolverine fan than you are a
a nick fan okay listen the the the
wolverines have had a lot more success
thanks to coach juan howard than the
knicks have had um but but ryan you're a
guy
who played in the nba 10 years who would
often times you know hear fans shout or
you would interact with fans
i know you and jimmy goldstein would
yuck it up at clipper games
um you guys talk about your hat
collection and your rhinestone boots
that you both share
oh my gosh but but the idea of now
hearing baseball in the bronx a guy's
throwing a baseball from left field into
alex verdugo's back and you mentioned
trey young and kyrie in the water bottle
you know what's going on with fans and
and reacting to players
and the interaction and do you have any
any memories from your days playing
where you would get into it with the
yoko like me
yeah you know what i didn't like to
sometimes fans get so excited
that they feel like they can say and do
anything to you
when they're very close to you and
sometimes you know we've i've had to
give reminders that hey man
you you say the wrong thing you're
you're only a couple steps away
and i've also kind of had to play
mediator you know i i played with matt
barnes
demarcus cousins the couple of guys who
who
you know will get into the audience so
i've i've kind of been the buffer
uh for the most part but i i just think
this there's a mix of
and ben you mentioned it earlier there's
a mix of social media
and there's a mix of covet and not being
able to go to games where a lot of these
fans have lost their dark minds
and i do want to throw this out a lot of
the true die hard knicks fans
are not blessed enough to make it to
games a lot of die-hard lakers a lot of
die-hard fans
don't can't afford to get into these
playoff games so
you know i'll give you some slack don't
judge a team
by the people in the arena the real fans
don't always get to make it in
so you know let's not judge everybody
buy a few bad apples or
you know a lot of nick apples i
appreciate that ryan you know i often
say i get the ny
i get the spike lee seats but it's not
on the wood it's like the nyu
film student seats she's got to have it
seat so i can touch
the willis reed jersey that's hanging
from the rafters ryan hollins joins the
show
ben lion's in for rich on the rich eisen
show game six
is gonna be tomorrow night and i'm so
grateful that we get more
nba finals basketball i love the stage
of the finals i love the moments i love
the iconic plays that we get to witness
that define
legacies when you look across the court
at chris paul
and how it felt after two games ryan
this was going to be the coronation of
one of your old teammates one of the
great leaders in nba history the leaders
of the
players association off the court just
like this celebration
of of plant-based chris paul i mean
beyond meat stock was going on
but now they've lost three in a row and
he's had some sloppy finishes
some bad turnovers does the narrative
around his legacy around how we view
chris paul
really change if they're that they are
not able to get it done in milwaukee
you know i play with chris and i know
that's the big monkey on his back is not
you know getting a championship or
making it to the finals
and i think he can only add to his
legacy uh i'm not among the you know the
group that puts him in the top five even
if he wins the championship top chris
paul is not a top five point guard
in my opinion but there's nothing but
respect on his name man
when you think of pick and roll chris
paul's name is synonymous with pick and
roll
and you know he's been haunted by some
of our playoff losses obviously as he
should be i know that
how hard chris takes these things but
you know he's in a do or die situation
we're going to see who chris is and i
don't think you can fault chris because
he's an undersized guard to not be able
to get his shot off in certain
situations
but the turnovers are the ones that are
going to count him so i i think he's
going to come out and play well man he's
got his back against the wall
and a lot of stars that we know shine in
that scenario and and i will credit you
with one thing ben and i i know you know
this as an analyst as a guy who follows
the league
this is very hard to call these finals
you don't know why j crowd is the only
guy with nba finals experience
that was bubble experience you know not
the disrespected laker championship but
none of these guys have been in the
finals before so we can't say hey man
devin booker historically goes off in
you know game sixes we don't know who
they are what they're gonna be so
i i'm just intrigued to see what chris
paul is going to look like in his last
chance
as a star player in the nba finals i
think if he comes back it's going to be
as a role player
but his last chance at this big moment
what is it going to look like
if i don't know anything i know chris is
going to compete but i'm interested to
see what is
up his sleeve ryan hollins joins the
show
former teammate at chris paul's the
pride of pasadena ucla zone and i'll
leave you with this ryan you know
tj was very excited this morning because
his favorite golfer colin morakawa won
the open championship you know he comes
from kenyatta flint ridge which is just
a nine iron from where you grew up so
what does collins
win mean for you on this monday morning
listen man anybody from the san gabriel
valley would be root for man i i was
i was part of the we i think you know in
our league was what our arcadia
hoover we didn't play la canada we used
to play in the la canada flint ridge
tournament so uh
you know any anybody from the town is
big man six two six all day [ __ ]
appreciate it man that's just big stuff
right there man good stuff ryan
appreciate you taking some time man
thank you so much
great to uh great to catch up any time
today
amen and don't you have no type of let
up you know you've been blazing this
thing this morning when i get off the
air i've been lying i'm holding you
accountable right now brother you've
been you've been you've been killing it
man no we appreciate it we appreciate
you wearing a three-piece suit only
doing it for radio too
take off the brooch and enjoy the rest
of your afternoon thanks so much dude
ryan hollins joins the show
um posted me up once and uh man when you
get posted up by an mba center
i don't care who they are that is a
different level of basketball
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here